so when are you gonna get on fire yeah
you you make too much money to be broke
where's all your money going Oh Beast
dadgum clueless I'm talking to you you
when are you gonna change your family
tree when are you gonna communicate with
your spouse and a healthy non-toxic way
about the money stuff huh yeah you what
are you gonna do it it's time I want
that for you I want you to win I believe
in you I think you can win I talk to
people just like you every day that have
done this stuff big people little people
young people old people white people
brown people I talked to all of them
they all are doing this stuff you can't
tell me you can't do it people look good
now shut up by people like you people
like you change their lives all the time
they just make a decision to do it they
get up off their butt leave the cave
kill something and drag it home man you
can do this I know you can do it I
actually believe you can do it more than
some of you believe you can do it
because I've seen so many I've seen so
many that had the the deck stacked
against them everything was against
there's no reason they should win and
they just decided they just made a
decision I am sick and tired of being
sick and tired I worked too hard to be
this broke I make too much money to be
this broke
once you start saying stuff like that
you ready to change and I gotta tell you
we've become a fan of yours at that
point is we are big fans of people who
are transforming their lives don't do
what everybody else is doing you're
gonna get what everybody else is getting
be not conformed to this world be
transformed how by the renewing of your
mind put something else in your noodle
baby change your life this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]